今日はこちらスティックラーメンです
相変わらず言葉の勉強の話ですけれども
特にそのリスニン聞くことなぜ大切なのか
どういうふうにしてその器具ことをその
有効にその言葉の勉強に脳のまあ1200
の中にそれを使おうかそういう話なんです
よ2
僕のチャンネルスキーであればぜひあの
登録してください
金のところで
定期てください知らせが届きますから
僕関して聴いていらっしゃればまずそこで
またコメントも残してください以上にもう
感謝します
あのねそのこちらの館のビリお蔵になって
いるならばその
いつものテーマですけれどもチェックと
読む
それが大事もう言葉から自分の頭にある
わけじゃないですから
外から自分の頭にもう入らないといけない
だからたくさんキーがなければならない
たくさん読まなければならない
読むのももちろん大切
この後ろに新しいそのバックグラウンド
ですねこの本棚
本棚道
その壁材があるけれども
その伊予いいようなもいいんですけれども
やはり聞くプトリスイングですね
今特にその新しい mp さん技術その他
があってですね
いつでもできます
ものすごいその数のそのも白い
内容のものいつでもあのインターネットで
探せるダウンロードして聴くことができ
ますだから非常に良い子なんですよマヤ
さあ
大蛇王きてですね朝ごはんを作る時にて
いきます今アラビア語と体集合ですけれど
も
いきます
寄付時にでそれが非常にやりやすいわけ
でしょ何の準備もいらないただその
iphone を撮ってそれを
茶屋へアルファードですねつけても
始まるわけですよしかし聞くときに
全部わかるわけじゃないんですね
3割も分かるとかまあ7割6割
そしていつもわからない部分があります
分からない部分があるからですねそれ
じゃあこれを読みたい読みたい
読みたくなるわけですよそのうわかなかっ
た部分を調べる
その読むときに知らない単語マーリン
キナリー
もう探す
保存する
a
それでもう一度聞くともう少しよくわかっ
てるでもそれでもわからなかった
醤油プロセスですね
で特にその新しい言葉
始まるときにあるいは者の
その僕のあるですよ
レバーがそんなに良くないとやはり同じな
よう繰り返してくる帰って来いくわけです
よ
そういう習慣がねえええ
始まるときでもそういうふうにします
繰り返して繰り返して聞くただ
あたを進んだ
あのジャムひど言いましょうかとの脳が寝
ないが必要かというとそれ繰り返しと
新しいもの秒いるわけですよ繰り返し
繰り返しだけではですねだんだん no 金
使ってくる面白くないから何も勉強しない
だから新しいもの楽しいもの
それを脳に与えるわけでしょ
しかしその新しいも広いものを聞いたり
止んだりしている中でもですね時々
元へ戻って簡単なものを繰り返してくるか
いて聞くのも大切なんですよなぜかという
と最初を聞いたときにいろんなものにキー
がつかなかったんですよ
そして新しいもっと分難しい内容
聞いたり読んだりした後でですねまーた元
へ戻ってですね30回も聞いたものもう
一度聞くと
朝五ん
作っているとき今までキーナー気がつか
なかった
その構造とか
単語がですね今日に気がつくわけですよ
それもそれをこれからじゃあ送料まあ理解
するあるいは使うように何だむにですね
それがこの31回名気が付いた時に非常に
助かるんですよだからそのバラエティが
必要なんですよだから言えばその聞く
リスニングのですね戦略にはその繰り返し
特に
最初の間最初の参加6ヶ月間の新しい言葉
その時にもう繰り返し繰り返し
まあ一番いいのがうちの人気のミニ
ストリート使えば客ミニストーリーの中に
は
その同じ単語がもう5回がぐらい繰り返さ
れてるわけですよ
クリッ繰り返されて
ないですね
ただ
あのそれでもストーリーもね次回もさん
次回もチェックこれ一派に聞くんじゃなく
て
ストーリーの
12345また
123456また12歳児ごーろくしち
はちこういうふうにですね結果的には各
ストーリーが30回も聞くことになった
わけですよそれだけ
脳にその
あれですよ分子の間にこういう
コネクションができているわけですよ
しかし先に言いましたようにその栗菓子
だけでは脳がつまらなくな
面白くない
も覚える効率がさがうそのから赤らしい
ものに挑戦しないといけない
でだから1200円ちょっと変わるそんな
も広いものをその
繰り返してくれ快適くっていうのはその
新しい単語を新しいその分布を構造その
なじみ磯路へ
あるですよ馴染みが出るために繰り返して
聞くんですよねただ新しいものは
新しい単語ん
そして少しずつこの言葉の勉強においては
ですね言葉の勉強のために聞くんじゃなく
て
新しい面白いなよう聞くために聞く
だから知らないうちにおもしろいたのしい
なよを聞いたり読んだりすることによって
言葉がそのレベルがだんだんだんだんよく
なってくるだから最初はま里言葉を勉強
するために聞くしかし
あとある程度その数字は上がった時点で
ですね
今度は
面白いないよ
楽しいないを聞く読む
それは場合によってはその映画へその
セリアネットフリックスのセラーとかめ
そういうものを楽しむためにてぃくま読む
a
しかし結果的には言葉の数ゆがああしかし
その時にでも時々
簡単なものミニストーリーみたいなものを
繰り返していくとその両方やることがまあ
効果的だと思いますで聞くことがですね
それを聞くときにいつもをこの集中しない
といけないということはないんですよ不
可能です
結局
ことがですね非常にその利点の一つはいつ
でもどこでもできますだから運転している
ときできます車の中電車の中
さあながらやってる時にいてもだから
もちろん100%
その収集できないわけですよしかしそれが
できなくてもいいんですよ6割7割8割
それでも十分ですねで不思議なブドウには
ですね
僕もそのじゃあ今座ってねわざと集中して
何かを聞くことをやろうと思えば集中でき
ないんですよ逆に
でもしう僕は他のことをやりながら
器具であればまあ6割な訛りは器具時々は
あのーどっか
まあ
ほかのことを考えてしかしまた戻ってきく
それの方が下手では座ってじゃあ今は
なきゃ行きますよともう5分経ったら火を
止めましたとことになるわけですよなぁ
それもまぁみんな客
勉強してる人が違うかもしれませんけれど
もその聞くことが=100%をその
集中力というのはそうじゃないんです
淫夢10%でも30%も50%ね集中でき
たらそのその分言葉が
あの自分の頭の中には入ってます
だから
楽しく
その最初の愛では繰り返しのおい
その聞くそういう戦略を使ってください
そしてある程度の数字になったら今度
面白いもの
keep 太志ラームまかなかった部分は
今どん読む ipad でリンクを使って
読むとそれで町化しいずれにしても
100%理解しましたとか集中できました
とかそれが必要はないです必要はないです
言葉がだんだんと雨のようにこれ
あのあるですよ脳が濡れて
なったられるようになってねそれでいい
ですよ
今友人ですから英語で言うとじゃ今日は
そこまであの
聞く google についての話でした
じゃどうもみなさんよろしくお願いしまー
す